laure brugnon bonjour bonjour vous êtes
responsable adjoint du marché des
professionnels et des entreprises sur le
site banque populaire val de france de
saint quentin en yvelines
aujourd'hui on va parler transformation
numérique des pme tpe et des artisans
ce sont vos clients ou comment vous est
saisi de cet enjeu bien écouter
effectivement à la banquière val de
france la transformation digitale est un
sujet qui nous intéresse c'est important
pour nous inciter nos clients à prendre
le virage de la transformation digitale
on a constaté finalement des nouveaux
comportements des nouvelles technologies
chaque jour nous passons trois heures
sur nos téléphones mobiles à faire des
achats à consulter les réseaux sociaux à
faire des recherches en 2019 on a passé
la barre des 19 des 100 milliards
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires sur
internet
c'est 10% du commerce de détail en
france 40 millions de dhs acheteurs
français et seulement 20% de nos
entreprises vente sur internet
donc pour nous en fait qui sommes
partenaires des professionnels et des
pme
c'est important de leur parler de ce
sujet ils doivent revoir leurs relations
avec les clients tandis vital que
finalement physique c'est un enjeu que
vous avez essayé depuis combien de temps
je dirais que ça fait deux trois ans que
on est vraiment sur ce sujet
concrètement ça se passe comment quand
vous recevez une entreprise qui
demandent justement du capital vous l'a
conseillé directement sur la
transformation numérique
alors finalement nous sommes nous sommes
aller par étapes la première chose que
nous avons faite c'est que nous avons
sensibilisé tous nos conseillers de
clientèle à aux enjeux de la
transformation digitale
donc c'est un sujet effectivement qu'ils
abordent un rendez vous avec leurs
clients
et nous avons également développé une
gamme complète de solutions pour
accompagner nos clients dans la
transformation digitale donc avec eux
nous évoquons leur visibilité sur
internet
nous les aidons finalement à être plus
visibles à aller chercher des nouveaux
clients nous parlons aussi de chiffre
d'affaires sur internet de vente sur
internet avec la création de sites
marchands et puis également nous leur
proposons une solution marketing digital
pour fidéliser leurs clients en
naturellement tout ça c'est un petit des
dépenses et nous finançons ses dépenses
de transformation digitale
vous venez de le dire vous conseillez
d'abord vos clients dans leur démarche
de transformation numérique mais
finalement votre coeur de métier c'est
le financement et je crois savoir que
vous proposez le pré socama dans le
cadre de la transformation numérique et
digital effectivement cette
transformation numérique elle n'est pas
gratuite donc nos clients professionnels
commerçants artisans et entreprises
engagent des dépenses de logiciels
dépeint parfois des dépenses
immatérielles et donc nous avons une
solution de financement qui s'appelle le
prêt socama transformation numérique qui
est un prêt qui permet de limiter les
garanties personnelles est totalement
dédié à cet objet pourquoi vous êtes
saisis de cet enjeu finalement la banque
populaire val de france
encore une fois la volonté d'accompagner
nos clients on est bon qu'ils historique
des commerçants artisans première banque
des pme
on ne pouvait pas ne pas prendre ce
virage avec eux de la transformation
numérique et ne pas s'adapter à leurs
besoins
est-ce que vous avez quelques exemples
concrets d'accompagnement alors oui j'en
ai j'en ai en tête
il s'agit d'un restaurateur qui est tout
près d'ici qui nous a sollicités pour
l'aider à fidéliser sa clientèle
donc nous avons une solution de
marketing digital qui permet en fait de
se constituer un fichier clients
associées à la carte bancaire
donc grâce à ça et se constituer un
fichier clients et puis ensuite il peut
envoyer des sms ou bien des emailings
pour proposer des offres promotionnelles
et les faire revenir dans son restaurant
et ainsi augmenter son chiffre
d'affaires on a l'exemple d'un
restaurateur dans les différentes
expériences dans les différents cas que
vous avez pu observer que sont les
secteurs qui sont plus demandeurs
justement de transformation digitale
ça concerne vraiment tous les
professionnels et toutes les entreprises
donc qui a pas un secteur qui est plus
intéressé qu'un autre mais j'ai un autre
exemple en tête il s'agit d'une ferme
qui dans le 78 et qui nous a sollicités
parce qu'elle avait la volonté
développer son chiffre d'affaires en
circuit court
donc on l'a aidé à créer son site
internet et à rendre ce site marchand
est donc là encore une fois on
on souhaite accompagner nos clients dans
le développement de leur chiffre
d'affaires qu'est ce que permet la
transformation digitale pour vos clients
justement plus de productivité plus de
clients plus de clients plus de vies
emilie visibilité plus d'adaptations
nouveaux comportements des consommateurs
vraiment accompagné la tendance
des nouvelles règles de consommation
leur bouillon merci beaucoup merci à
vous responsable adjointe du marché des
professionnels et des entreprises chez
banque populaire val de france